I finished about 20 minutes ago it's
currently 11 38 p.m the game was almost
four and a half hours
and
yeah that was a long one it was a long
fight super interesting
um I'm probably gonna try and keep this
brief because I have not had dinner yet
but there's a one restaurant that's open
for the next several hours so uh
hopefully they have good food but anyway
um I was playing Eugene unite who is a
feeding master and I did a bit of prep
before the game decided to play Pawn to
E4
um he played C5 this was expected Knight
C3 and I saw in his previous tournament
games and online games he's mainly
played G6 and Knight C6 and I was
prepared for both moves
um more so for G6 but he decided to play
Knight C6 he told me after the game that
uh he's seen that I've I've played H4
before and it's a scary line so he went
for Knight C6 and here I played online
that I learned years ago
um that I haven't played so much
recently but it starts with Bishop to B5
Knight D4 and Bishop C4
now recently Knight F3 is kind of the
more trendy move and probably
objectively the best move for whites but
Bishop C4 was an old line I used back
when I was maybe rated around 2100 and I
use this to get to the master level
and there is a trap here which my
opponent had fallen for in 2015. so I
thought that maybe he would not
necessarily fall for it again but
um maybe be out of his comfort zone in
this opening and the trap that he filed
for in 2015 was after G6 92 Bishop G7
takes takes Queen F3 uh he played the
very natural E6 which walks into Knight
B5 and White's getting massive
initiative I actually gave a lecture in
the St Louis chess club all about this
line and the point is after D6 Queen A3
and White's doing really well here so
black really has to know what they're
doing uh the best move is Knight H6 in
this position and I was prepared to go
into the sign but instead of G6 my
opponent played E6 and this is a
different line entirely
um I I checked this before the game I
played Knight E2 you played Knight F6
and I Castle
and in this position there's another
really cool trap for white that black
could easily stumble into if the black
player is not familiar with this line
and the trap is if black plays D5
which is actually the most common move
played on each us uh this walks into
takes takes
and then Knight take uh wait no not
Knight takes D4 but Knight takes D5 and
after Knight takes D5 Knight takes D4
Pawn takes D4 white has just sacrificed
peace but there's massive compensation
after Queen H5
and this is known to be really really
good for white uh Bishop E6 looks like
it defends everything but it walks into
rookie one and the pawn is pinned so The
Bishop's hanging and the bishop is
pinned so the knight's also hanging
attack twice and black has really no
good defense here if Knight F4 then
there's Bishop B5 and uh yeah King E7
Queen G5 will pick up the Knight
and the reason why I'm showing this line
is because
my opponent
presumably knew about this and he played
the best move instead of going for D5
immediately he went for Pawn E6 and
after I play Pawn A4 preventing B5 he
then plays D5
so it's the same position as the trappy
line I just showed but with the
inclusion of A6 and A4 the line actually
doesn't work for whites and just to show
after takes takes takes takes takes
takes Queen H5 it's the same position I
just showed uh but the problem is after
Bishop E6 rookie one Knight F4 there's
no Bishop B5 check and this is why black
was very wise to play A6 and basically
include a6a4 and this would be just
losing for white
so my opponent knew about this and I I
knew about this too so going back just
goes to show the subtle Nuance of the
line that uh seemingly innocuous Asics
just changes the whole variation and
instead of sacking the piece I took once
on D5 and then played Bishop to A2
now I was still prepared I had this
position on my computer before the game
uh he played 96. I played Pawn D3
he played Bishop D6 and I played Knight
G3 and I spent a little bit of time in
the last few moves because I was trying
to remember what I looked at before the
game but um once I played Knight G3 I
was sure that this is still within my
computer preparation
and then here he very quickly blitzed
out the move upon H5
and I asked him after the game if this
was preparation on his parts and he told
me that he looked at this position for
about 30 seconds before they came so we
both have this position on our computer
before the game and the thing about this
position is it's very close to equal
after the following line which we went
into and I I was still prepared I I took
on D5 still following stockfish Knight
takes D5 Bishop takes D5 Bishop takes G3
so I temporarily won a Pawn on D5 but uh
black is winning it back because my
Bishop's attacked I have to take on E6
and then he has Bishop takes H2 I knew
that this line was possible before the
game and this was basically the worst
case scenario of my preparation I knew
that this line is objectively just very
close to equal as we're gonna see
but uh I thought that there's still
chances for an interesting game even
though a lot of pieces get traded early
so I went ahead I took back and then he
played the move Queen to D6
and in this position I forgot exactly
what I checked before the game because I
was pretty sure I checked the move
Bishop takes E6 and then the final move
of my preparation would have been Queen
F3
but I did not check the in-between move
Queen D6
and when he played this move I was very
tempted to just play King G1 and after
takes go for Queen F3 but I spent a lot
of time here because there's another
interesting option of playing the move
Bishop to F4
and he told me after the game that he
just overlooked this move when he played
Queen D6 and the point is if I play
Bishop F4
after takes there's Pawn to G3 and he
has no time to recapture the bishop
because the Queen's attacked and I spent
a lot of time calculating the variations
here after Queen F6 I was looking at
takes takes and I was trying to assess
this position I calculated this this and
rookie one but I just wasn't sure that
I'm able to play for much of an edge
because the prospect of like G5 and H4
looks scary might be two Pawn is hanging
in some cases so after a long think
I decided to not play Bishop F4
but to just go back to G1 you can see
the time stamps here it's been about 12
minutes and then he took on E6 so he
essentially got a free Tempo improving
the queen worshiping my king back and
now I play Queen F3 and at this point
I'm definitely out of my preparation but
uh I had a decent sense of the plans in
the position like obviously Queen F3 I'm
trying to activate and prepare Bishop F4
and it's a question where black should
put the king here so he went ahead and
castled I played Bishop four and then he
played Queen D5 which I think is a very
fine move just offering a queen trade
and here I realized that I can't really
keep Queens on the board without making
a big concession if I play the move
Queen E3
uh
honestly I didn't take so much time to
make this decision but um
I was scared of like G5 and h4h3 I
thought blacks attack uh can very often
be quicker so I decided to take the
queen
and after Bishop takes D5 the position
looks very close to just being a dead
draw like obstaclear Bishops equal pawns
but there's still some imbalances in the
position
and when I played my next move I thought
I was being very clever because
essentially the the main thing to
realize is Black's biggest liability is
the C5 pawn and what I really want to do
is get a setup with something like A5
and B3 and ensure that the pawn can't be
defended and I also don't want to give
back time uh to play this move Ponzi for
so I was dreaming of a setup with like
A5 B3 Bishop E3 where the pawn will be
uh just long-term weakness but the
problem is if I play for example A5
right away then there's Pawn C4 and
black can basically trade off the pawn
and if I play Pawn B3 or the way then
black can play Pawn E5 and then B6 and
then Black's just really solid
so I decided to play the move Rook to A3
which is not the first move that came to
mind but the idea is I'm preventing Pawn
C4 because then I can meet that with
Rook C3 essentially winning a pawn
um and the calculation is this
um oh actually Rook C3
probably isn't as good as just taking
because then takes Rook C3 B5 B3 wins a
bishop
so long story shorts black can't get rid
of the pawn right away and B6 would run
into A5 and the pawns would uh very soon
become weak
so when I played this move I was feeling
good I thought like I'm putting a little
bit of positional pressure on black
preparing this
um eventually I want to play this and
this and really question how Lock's
gonna defend the pawn and then he played
the move Bishop C6
which um I think was a very fine move
essentially tying me down to A4 so if I
play Rook C3 then black is probably
happy to trade so I I want Pawn A5 here
and when I played this move I realized
that he can get away with playing Pawn
C4 which I was expecting uh he didn't go
for this but I thought after it takes
and Rook D4
it's probably very close to equal but
then he told me after the game that um
he was scared of Bishop E3 takes an idea
of this
which is actually really interesting
because if takes there's like Rook D1
and very close to having some mating
ideas for white with the D file and the
bishop on B6
so for that reason
he didn't play C4 he played the move
Pawn to each four
and here it's about to get really crazy
and I'm just gonna show the next few
moves because
uh in this position I was not
anticipating what was going to happen
Max I played King H2 because he wants to
play H3 like if I get complacent to play
Rook C3 H3 G3 H2 is checkmates so I did
not want to get mated I thought the King
on H2 is just a better Square for the
king because if H3 that I can safely
play G3
but then he hits me with the move Pawn
to G5
which I did not see coming and I
realized I can't take the pawn because
Rook G8 and my G2 Pawn hangs and this
would be very ugly for whites so I have
to lose time moving my Bishop
and then he plays Panda G4
and he's basically sacking the C Pawn to
get a really scary looking attack
and during the game I thought I had to
just go into this line
um I took on C5 and at this point I
really wasn't sure what was going on
because after G3
I take he takes I take my king is really
exposed and The Rook check is coming and
my Jeep two Pawn is falling
but once we got to this position I
realized that it's really not simple for
black because
white is currently up two pawns and I
didn't see any forcing lines that allow
black to win back both pawns or just
exploit my king like it seems like it's
close to a mating net but my king can
almost in every line find some nice
safety so what ended up happening was
Rook dg8 was played I play King F4 which
looks super risky but I have to play
King F4 because if I play this and Rook
G2 and C2 Falls and uh I think I'd be in
trouble here
so after King F4
uh he took on G2 with the bishop I
should know that if he takes with a rook
I have to holding on to the second rank
so he took with the bishop and then I'm
very quickly able to consolidate I play
Rook F2 he gives a check I play King E3
and at this point my king is guaranteed
to just find safety and I'm up a pawn
because it's four on two on the queen
side he does have this extra past F Pawn
but it can't really become dangerous
anytime soon
so I was feeling really good here I'm in
great shape to win the game also the
time situation Favored Me
uh next several moves were very natural
for lights after King D2 Rook E8 I was
playing pretty quickly I thought my Rook
is better just on an open file you play
King D7 I played Pawn D4 Rook H5 and
Rook G1 so I was um yeah I was having a
very big time Advantage I got kind of my
ideal setup defended Bishop safe King
more active Rooks and his Queen side
pawns are fixed and I thought my idea
from this position would be to
eventually play C4 kick the bishop and
then later play D4 D5 and just keep
gaining space But as we're gonna see it
wasn't so simple
and I really struggled to
find a breakthrough
um so I'm I'll play through the next
several moves uh relatively quickly
there's a bit of dancing around
but um I managed to get a really nice
Bishop on B6 and get his King very close
to just being mated because the King has
almost no legal moves seems like C4 is
coming and I was dreaming of teleporting
this Rook to C5
so after Rook Gates I played rookie 2
preparing rookie five he plays Rook 2 G3
which I think is a nice defensive move
because now if I play rookie five he can
defend with Rook G5 and I can't quite
deliver mates
so I played King C3 he plays Rook G5
and this is where the dancing begins
because I was struggling to make
progress I moved back to D2 I realized
my king was just blocking my C Pawn he
played Rook G1 I played Rook d8 Rook H1
and I finally Advanced the C pawn and at
this point I had the idea of playing
King C3 Rook B2 and then B5 cb5
um or ab5 cb5 and that would potentially
be checkmates of course if the Rook
isn't defending but it seemed like
there's so many mating ideas with the
potential for B5 or D4 D5
but then he plays rookie one and my king
is a little bit uh of a Target because
he's getting ready to deliver checks and
after King's C3 Brook C1 I was really
tempted to play King D4 but I wasn't
sure about Rook H4 and then where my
king would try and find safety because
move back and then check and then move
back and then Rook H1 again
so I decided to try and trade a pair of
Rooks with Rook C2 he played Rook B1 I
played Rook B2 and we do trade the Rooks
but the problem with trading the Rooks
is I don't have the extra Rook to try
and generate The Mating threats so it's
still a question how white can win this
position and of course I really want to
play D4 D5 but whenever I play D4 my
Seaport Pawn hangs
so he played Rook F1
and um
yeah I really wanted to play D4 here
because after takes check if King D5 I
have this move
oh but this doesn't work because after
this this this the bishop Defensor Rook
um so yeah that wouldn't work at all
there's also this move and B4 is
attacked so
um I can't play D4 yet I play King C3
he played Rook H1
and then for the next several moves I
was just trying to find the optimal
Square for my king I was imagining if I
can get my king to E7 that would set up
rook D6 check so I play King D4
but then he plays Rook H5 and he just
cuts me off and my king can't cross the
fifth rank so I walk towards this Rook
he checks key for Rook H5 King F4 but
then Rook F5 check and I'm not making
progress so I move back
and then I decide to try to do something
on the queen side uh with King C3 Rook
H1 King C2 Rook F1 King B3 I was
imagining maybe I can get my king to A4
and play B5 but then the problem is if I
play King A4 he gives rookie one check
so I'm really not making any progress
I play King A3 back to B2
and at this point
um we've already repeated at least one
of the positions twice and I was scared
of repeating the same position three
times
um I think this is one of the positions
we had twice so I decide to shift my
Rook to a different Square I play Rook 2
B8 and even though I I no longer cut the
king off the king is still tied down to
defending B7
so it was a different way of trying to
make progress he plays Rook F5 I'm
liking E2 and then eventually I found
what turned out to be a better Square
for my Bishop on F4
and this way the king is still
restricted
but the bishop controls the D6 square
and we're going to see the usefulness of
the square very soon after Rook H3 Rook
to d8
and when we got to this position I was
kind of breathing a sigh of relief
because black is not stopping Rook D6
and if I get in Rook D6 then the king
would be forced to C7 and at the very
least the bishop would fall with check
so at this point
um he played maybe what is only moved to
trying fights which is B5
but then I happily play Rook G6 and
start consuming the queen side pawns
after it takes Bishop Chuck King D2
uh we played a few more moves Rook F3
Chuck King 8 Rook G5
and he finally resigned in this position
um so I took a ton of work to
actually win this game I should note the
reason why Bach resigned is because the
bishop is hit and A6 and rookie this
coming and yeah I'm either promoting or
mating so there's really no hope for
luck
but uh it was a super long game 72 moves
uh I spent so much energy and towards
the end of the game I mean we were both
just living on the increments
um there's no extra time after move 40
so it really just turned into a game of
instincts and uh yeah just trying to
grind down the ending
so I think I'm fortunate to win this
game because
um I really didn't get much of an edge
out of the opening I'm sure at some
points he probably could have equalized
um now I haven't checked so closely with
engine uh and I don't really have time
to do so right now because I'm kind of
hungry and sleepy but I do hope you
enjoyed this recap stay tuned for the
next game
um it will be round two starts at 11 A.M
Pacific Time
June 9th and I believe that game will be
covered by Jonathan trance on my twit
channel so be sure to check out uh
twitch.tv I'm Rosen and he'll be
covering
um my game with commentary uh I'll leave
links below to the leechas broadcast and
the tournament page but uh thanks so
much for watching I do appreciate all
the kinds comments and good luck wishes
in my announcement video and and uh yeah
stay tuned for more and I'll see you
guys soon